[Music]
I started most of my programs when I was
teaching with an exercise that I call 20
questions which I borrowed in part from
the Organization for tropical studies
which does this exercise with graduate
students whom it's got in Costa Rica or
other field sites tropical field sites
it involves taking people out you have
to have access to nature you have to
have access to a fair bit of nature
taking people out and asking them in
advance to just take out pen paper no
phone water if they need it but even you
know no food promised them that they're
not going to die out there and be true
to your promise make sure that you don't
abandon them you take people out and you
drop them in some spot and and if you
have a group of people you drop them out
of sight of one another and you say sit
here for two hours I will be back in two
hours
but for these two hours just sit here
and be and let your senses start to tell
you what you're experiencing for a while
I'm depending on how long it's been
since you've really spent time in nature
it's just going to be your brain
yammering yeah you're telling you that
you have things to do this is a waste of
your time that you're bored that you
wish you weren't being told to do this
at some point two hours is usually long
enough for that to fade away and so the
instruction is let the all wash over you
but try then to start watching and
hearing and smelling if you like what it
is that is going on around you and at
whatever point you feel like it start
start writing down questions that you
have about what you're experiencing and
the goal is to write down 20 but if you
write down five that's fine if you write
down 40 that's fine too
and try to make the questions be about
what's going on external to your head as
opposed to questions that are that your
own brain is generating that have
nothing to do with what you're actually
great sing right now so people spend two
hours out in nature doing this and a you
know I've done this in the Pacific
Northwest I've done it in the San Juan
Islands of in the high desert of
Washington in Ecuador in Panama in the
Amazon all sorts of places and it you
get different results in each of these
places because the questions that people
can ask when there are parrots around
versus mountains are quite different but
you then you pick them up you say okay
you're free now and you're free either
for the rest of the day and we'll come
back together bring your questions
tomorrow or at least for a few hours
like you don't have to think about this
but go just let this percolate
well coming back together say it's the
afternoon of the same day you break
students up and to break people up into
groups of four or five okay
give your questions to the person on
your left and have them choose their
favorite question on your from your list
and you choose your favorite question
from the list and so in a group of five
end up with ten questions that people
really really like that they had written
down and now start to categorize them in
the case of an educational environment
that's about discovering evolutionary
truths I tend to ask them to categorize
questions on the basis of you know is it
just a factual question is it a what is
what was that bird right you know what
is the name of that cloud formation is
it a how style question approximate
question like how does the bird find the
flower or is it a wide style question an
adaptive question an ultimate level
question why is that bird moving back
and forth between those two flowers the
entire town that was here and so you
can't you have the students categorized
which begins to establish and borders
around types of questions and you can
begin to see that the what questions are
the kinds of questions that with the
right expert or the right search term
you can pretty quickly answer the kinds
of questions that people who are newly
spending time in nature are going to ask
about
what is that our probably answered
already out there by someone and
probably a lot of people know the answer
to and it's discoverable and it doesn't
go very far very interestingly right
what is it we got a name for it there
you go
move on but the how and the why
questions are where we can really start
to explore how we know what's true how
we make claims of truth so this is this
is the basis of epistemology how is it
that we make claims of truth and how
would we begin to know if what we think
is true is actually true and so this
this is the beginning of the scientific
method this is let us begin with a begin
with observation pose a question figure
out what the hypothesis would be that
would answer a particular question and
then figure out how we would begin to
address the hypothesis that is a
scientific approach to two questions
that could just be they could be
addressed any number of ways and so I
have I have people spend an hour hour
and a half sometimes doing this in small
groups and then we share and then they
write these down in posters and then we
go around and talk about some of the
best ones from each group and it's
amazing it is high-energy so in a class
of 25 or 50 and a group of 25 or 50
people it's too much really would be
better in a group of 10 or 15 probably
but still it would be higher energy
because everyone is vested everyone has
a question that they really think is
theirs and they also interestingly
almost always have an answer they think
is right whether or not they have any
basis to think it's right they haven't
done the science right they haven't
actually gone out and tested the
hypothesis they've done the first parts
of the science they've made an
observation
they've positive they've asked a
question they posited an explanation
which is a hypothesis that might answer
that question but they haven't yet gone
out and tried to figure it out but they
are really sure and so to watch the
sureness in their room come face-to-face
with other people who haven't yet
considered the question who on the spur
of the moment come up with alternate
explanations is both an exercise in in
how science is done and how we come to
understand what things are true and what
things aren't but also an exercise and
watching human
about how someone who yesterday didn't
care about this thing at all now is so
sure and is so intricately tied their
identity to this thing being true
whether or not it is that they can end
up yelling at someone who's just saying
well maybe it's this instead and so you
you actually begin to get real grip
cohesion out of the chaos of people
disagreeing sometimes stridently
sometimes angrily with one another
because all it takes is a step back to
say okay how would we know why do you
care so much why is this about emotion
right now as opposed to let's figure out
how we would actually come to now
[Music]